i told you about that
tell you about the one guy that had that
told me this is after trump had
after trump had had lost
he he was about to step down and i
this guy sent me an email saying look i
have evidence of government corruption
and this and this and this
and so these guys will say this kind of
stuff and and if if they're persistent
enough and they
you know they sound credible this guy
seemed kind of credible like i was like
yeah
it's worth a phone call i was like all
right here's my cell number shoot me an
email or
me i'll i'll talk to you at this time i
talked to him
he was telling me about how trump was
working
was it was it working with the military
i forget who he was oh and
china and that they were about to bomb
no china was going to bomb some facility
that was under
like mount rushmore and they were going
to collapse the entire
uh um our entire economy and we were
doing that and he's like trump's been
working with him the whole time and he
goes on and on and on
and i'm listening to him he's just nuts
and i'm listening to him and i went bro
you you do understand that
after tomorrow trump's no longer
president he's like that's what they
want you to believe bro
oh he's gonna when this happens oh no
he's still president
he's gonna be president nah bro i'm
pretty sure
that he just the guy was and and
honestly
like i didn't at now when these guys
call like when they say crazy [ __ ] in
the comment section now i'm like
email me bro we got to get you on the
podcast yeah yeah like
i need to talk to you this is crazy [ __ ]
you're like right right bro
this podcast has turned me into a
conspiracy theorist oh i'm i'll bet
the [ __ ] i get on here are
[ __ ] wigging my are changing
the way my brain works so convincing and
you know you can manipulate facts you
can tweak it here and tweak it here to
shift it one way or the other
the media does it all the time but you
get somebody who's really good you can
man you can really twist twist up some
stories
um yeah i don't know i kind of missed
trump now that he's not in office
yeah he was crazy he was [ __ ]
phenomenal entertainment he was great
for media
great for the internet there was a
headline every single [ __ ] day about
him
i miss him i truly miss him listen it's
sad watching biden
like i feel bad like i'm like pathetic
god i hope there's no major decisions
that have to be made like this is
this is bad it's [ __ ] pathetic bro
just watching did you watch his
coronavirus speech the other day no
i can't watch everybody i'm begging you
get vaccinated
and now they're saying they're going to
come to your doors and vaccinate you
they're going to go door-to-door like
the [ __ ] consensus thing have you
been vaccinated
no no he ain't getting backed me near me
neither we're none of us are getting
back i'm not doing
it they're not implementing they're not
implanting those chips in me
yeah hulk hogan told me all i need to do
is save my prayers and take my vitamins
so that's what i'm doing
was it hulk hogan or joe rogan i don't
know i think it was hulk
same thing good time good time
i love your truck do you think he's
gonna be president of 2024
listen would that be hilarious i would
love it i would i will but he's never
done that before
i [ __ ] i know right are you sure
i don't think every anybody's ever been
in a term left for a term and then come
back for another no i don't think it has
either
yeah we have to look at that somebody's
smarter than us i'm pretty pleased i'm
pretty sure that's true
yeah yeah the trump's good did you see
tuc tucker carlson
already sold one of the trumps did you
really had three go get it show it to us
let me
let me see what that [ __ ] looks like
well the one that sold this sold well
you got
two right there no okay you wanted me
you wanted me to walk off with the
headphones on snapchat
oh yeah austin will get it oh no austin
changing the battery you can get the get
the
get the trump first you were that's what
you were playing and that was the plan
that's like when someone's holding
holding a glass look at that beauty yeah
ah yeah hold it uh get a hold on that
side of you
what side basically where your head was
before
there you go boom trump 2024
are you selling this [ __ ] on your
website no
you have to email me or go to my website
and get my email
website no you can go to um no no you
go to my youtube channel my youtube
channel there you go i gotta plug the
youtube channel
what is it inside true crime matt cox
yeah it's just matt cox or inside true
crime it'll show up
so explain to me what was your process
in creating this picture
explain to me your creative process for
this
i use the president it looks like it was
printed on a [ __ ] printer
no no it's a it's a screen it's a screen
print
then i go back and i paint i paint over
the screen print
then i screen print it again to get the
little dots
because i like the little dots what's
the word what's the term for that the
little dots
um like little dots um i don't know
isn't there an artistic term don't you
have a fine arts degree
it's just mean i mean you're just i i
don't know what do you mean what is it i
don't it was pointillism but it's not
possible
okay there you go there you go
pointillism um
yeah yeah uh oh it's it's basically this
is it's called a modified screen print
it's where you're using
you know it's like i love how you did
the sides too sorry how you painted the
sides always paint this
that's that's [ __ ] dope i even threw
a star in there
his mom or grandma would pay top dollar
for that thing right there
[Music]
so would my my dad probably would love
it too tell people love trump
people do love you know what i was
thinking about doing he's fun he was fun
what what that one's cool too i like
that one it's kind of like a
a burgundy background merlot merlot yeah
merlot
the maryland monroe's cell i've already
got three marilyn monroe i did like five
marilyn monroes three of them are sold
already
would you do a charles manson i should i
i could do a charles manson
then you would have the manson and the
monroe the maryland and the manson
so it's just so corny you're gonna
you're you're gonna
we can send them to marilyn manson
you're gonna make a great dad though
you've got he always tells the dad jokes
right they're corny dads yeah
oh my gosh so people you're selling
these these things on your website
or on your they just got to email you
something yeah you just emailed me how
much
what do they go for i i uh 285 and that
mean and i mail them to you for that
oh really i include include shipping
that includes shipping and like a person
or something i mean if somebody will
they're already signed in
cox yeah i sign them you know if
somebody said hey can you sign the back
or something
whatever i don't care i even got special
boxes that fit them perfectly i mean
it's it's nice
i got it down and i've the bubble gum
girl one like i've sold
a bunch of those really yeah but yeah
yeah yeah rob zombie one
and then the um i've i've started
selling the the screamer
yeah the way the guy's screaming yeah i
love the one
what about the special one the really
special oh my god
all right so i do get guys and this is
it is it is weird
it's really gay i knew he was going to
say he yeah
you have to deal with it listen
guys ask me all the time bro i want a
portrait i'm like of who and they're
like of you and i'm like
i don't know you know i haven't done one
you know what i'll do
i'll just do a screen print i'll screen
print them and then i can paint them in
and do whatever and i'll throw some
sharks in there and then that'll be it i
can knock those out and i'll sell them
for the same thing
what are you doing why are you laughing
because it's just funny like you someone
what am i supposed to say so you say
i want a portrait and this is what you
come up with this is what i came up with
and danny hates it let's see it i don't
hate it
we don't care about it i think it's
[ __ ] beautiful i think you don't do
not you just you you
i mean hilarious hilarious okay it is
[ __ ]
comical awesome's got it but it's great
i love it i'm not hating on it oh okay
it's interesting it's interesting so
this is matt's
self-portrait yeah
oh my what do you call that that look
you're doing right there what's that
face
that's me messing with
my iphone camera
that was it that's like hey what's up
baby
do you not make that face in prison all
right come on man what's going on how
much does that one
how did you take that photo it was my my
iphone i put it on on a stand
and i was taking pictures and that was
one of i took a bunch of pictures and i
looked at that one i said i
like that one i sent it to a couple of
people and
they were like yeah that's good i mean
i'm trying to send a couple of those out
no no just the photo oh i got you um and
that was it
how much is that one going for that's at
least 500
that's 4.99 free shipping all day
anyway
i guess i should have sent it to danny
first yeah you sent to me a while ago
you were going to make it an nft
yeah yeah we're going to make it into
nft
i can't get enough of that painting i
want to put that on my wall
you i could see that in your house
you